Os voy a proponer un reto. Cuando terminéis
de ver este vídeo, id a la cocina y abrid
el frigorífico. Os reto a que encontréis
algo que esté producido fuera de vuestro
país. Si estáis en España, entonces os
reto a que encontréis algo que esté producido
fuera de la Unión Europea.
Fijaos en un detalle… vuestro teléfono
móvil está hecho en más de 20 países distintos.
Vuestra ropa está hecha en China o Bangladesh.
Y es probable que hasta la empresa en la que
trabajáis sea de otro país. Es normal ¿Verdad?
Vivimos en un mundo globalizado. Sin embargo,
la comida, o más concretamente, la agricultura
es todavía un mundo hiperprotegido.
De hecho, no os equivoquéis… las guerras
comerciales no son un invento de Donald Trump.
En realidad, el sector primario lleva décadas
inmerso en una guerra fría. Y por eso, no
es nada raro encontrarse de vez en cuando
con titulares como este.
Pero no sólo hablamos de aranceles. En realidad,
los aranceles son solo un arma más para atacar
a los mercados extranjeros. Pero hay otras
igual o más letales.
Por ejemplo, EEUU se gasta cada año más
de 20.000 millones de dólares en subvenciones
y ayudas a la agricultura ¿Os parece mucho?
¡Pues esperad un momento! Porque la Unión
Europea se gasta muchísimo más. En este
caso, hablamos de una suma equivalente a 72.000
millones de dólares. Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué
tienen que ver las subvenciones con las guerras
comerciales? ¡Pues mucho!
Por ejemplo, este brick de leche que veis
en la pantalla cuesta unos 60 céntimos de
euro en un Supermercado de España. De esos
60 céntimos, 30 van para el ganadero que
tiene las vacas. Pero en realidad, este ganadero
ganaría unos 44 céntimos, porque la Unión
Europea le paga una subvención de 14 céntimos
por cada litro de leche que vende.
Gracias a esta subvención, el ganadero puede
vender barato sin perder dinero. Y eso explica
que, por ejemplo, en Europa nadie compra azúcar
africano. O que incluso en África, los productores
europeos o estadounidenses les quiten cuota
de mercado a los productores locales.
Sin embargo, las cosas podrían empezar a
cambiar. Y no, en este caso, el abanderado
del libre mercado no es Estados Unidos, ni
Japón, ni Australia… hablamos de la mismísima
Unión Europea.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el hecho de
que un Presidente de la República Francesa
cuestione las ayudas europeas a la agricultura
es… como si un hipster cerrara su cuenta
de Instagram. Algo nunca visto. Durante años,
la llamada “Política Agraria Común”,
también conocida como la PAC, era uno de
los pilares de la Unión Europea. Pero las
cosas podrían cambiar mucho más rápido
de lo que nos pensamos.
Así que la pregunta es ¿De verdad Europa
está dispuesta a liberalizar su agricultura?
¿Veremos el fin de las guerras comerciales
de los alimentos? Y lo que es más importante
¿Es eso una buena o una mala noticia? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero antes,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
¿PARA QUÉ SIRVE LA PAC?
Vamos a
imaginar que tenemos un cultivo de trigo en
Valladolid, en España, que por cierto, es
la región de donde yo soy oriundo.
Recogemos la cosecha y la vamos a vender al
mercado. La última vez lo vendimos por unos
200€ por tonelada. Así que parece razonable
que esta vez lo podremos vender por un precio
similar ¿Verdad? Bueno, pues resulta que
en este momento, el trigo cotiza muy por debajo,
y que sólo nos pagan 170€ por tonelada.
Pues esta es la realidad a la que se enfrentan
todos los agricultores del mundo. Por ejemplo,
el precio de un iPhone es el mismo ahora que
hace un año. Sin embargo, tanto el trigo,
como el maíz, el petróleo o cualquier otra
materia prima, puede cambiar de un día para
otro.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué? Pues
porque las materias primas son iguales en
todas partes! Seguro que ninguno de vosotros
sabría decirme de dónde viene el trigo con
el que se hace el pan que habéis comido hoy
¿verdad? Pasa lo mismo con la gasolina que
ponemos en el coche. No sabemos de dónde
viene ni nos importa. Sólo queremos que sea
lo más barata posible. La diferencia es que
hay muy pocos países que produzcan zumo de
dinosaurio. Sin embargo, campos de trigo,
o de patatas… los hay en todas partes. Y
basta que haya una buena cosecha en tal sitio
para que el precio caiga en picado. A eso
hay que sumarle el tiempo. Si un año llueve
poco, o llueve demasiado, o tenemos un invierno
más frío de lo normal… todo nuestro negocio
se nos viene abajo. En otras palabras… que
en principio parece imposible que un agricultor
pueda sacar algún beneficio ¿No OS parece?
Sin embargo, necesitamos agricultura porque,
por desgracia, el zumo de dinosaurio y los
iPhones no se pueden comer. Así que ¿Qué
podemos hacer para poder tener alimentos y
que, a la vez, los agricultores no se mueran
de hambre? Os puede parecer una tontería
pero este es uno de los problemas más complicados
de la política y la economía.Y
aquí es donde entra la Política Agraria
Común, también conocida como la PAC. Este
es el sistema con el que la Unión Europea
protege a los agricultores.Hablar de la PAC
es hablar de uno de los pilares de la Unión
Europea. Está entre nosotros desde antes,
desde los años 60, es decir, mucho antes
que el Euro o el Espacio Schenghen. Es más
¿A que no adivináis quién es el Padre político
de esta Política Agraria Común? ¡Exacto!
El por entonces presidente de Francia: nuestro
amigo Charles
de Gaulle.
Si lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik
ya sabéis que De Gaulle no era, precisamente,
un amigo del libre mercado ni, en general,
de nadie que no fuera él mismo. Así que
cuando Francia entró en el Mercado Común
Europeo, lo que luego pasaría a ser la Unión
Europea, puso una condición: “vale, nosotros
entramos pero tenéis que prometernos que
nadie va a hacerle la competencia a nuestros
granjeros “. Y así es como nació la PAC,
una política tan intervencionista que, a
su lado, Pablo Iglesias parece Warren Buffet.
Básicamente, para compensar las posibles
pérdidas de los agricultores cuando bajan
los precios de las materias primas, Europa
les da dinero contante y sonante. Por ejemplo,
si tenemos un establo con vacas en España,
Bruselas nos va a dar todos los años una cantidad
de dinero por cada vaca que tengamos.Y si
queremos comprar una nueva máquina para ordeñar,
más moderna, que nos permita ser más productivos,
Bruselas también tiene toda clase de ayudas.
De esta forma, no sólo garantizamos que los
agricultores pueden sobrevivir a las subidas
y bajadas de los precios. También nos aseguramos
que ningún africano, ni latinoamericano,
ni asiático, pueda vender nada en territorio
Europeo.
Como os podéis imaginar, todas estas ayudas
suponen mucho dinero.
Para que os hagáis una ida, en los años
90, la PAC representaba el 80% de todo el
presupuesto de la Unión Europea. Y hoy en
día, que Europa se ha vuelto más grande
y tiene más competencias, hablamos del 40%
¿Y a que no adivináis qué país es el que
más dinero recibe? ¡Exacto! ¡Francia!¡Pero
esperad un momento porque la cosa no se queda
aquí! Europa cuenta con otras dos armas secretas
para evitar que bajen los precios de las materias
primas: las cuotas y los aranceles.
Por ejemplo, para evitar que bajara el precio
de la leche, Europa ponía un límite a la
producción de cada país. Es decir, que si
tú tenías una granja con vacas en España,
sólo podías vender un máximo de litros.
Y por supuesto ¿Quién era el principal beneficiado
de estas políticas? ¡Exacto! ¡El país
que las inventó! ¡Francia! Como os podéis
imaginar, esta política de cuotas, generaba
toda clase de problemas entre los estados
miembros. Y por eso, Europa ha terminado por
retirarla, para disgusto de los franceses.
Y, por supuesto, también tenemos los aranceles,
que son como balas de francotirador para evitar
que se cuelen productos extranjeros en suelo
europeo. Por ejemplo, imaginad que somos un
agricultor argentino y producimos café. Pues
bien, si queremos vender nuestros granos de
café CRUDOS, es decir, tal cual salen de
la planta, sin procesar, Europa nos los compra
sin poner ningún arancel ¿Por qué? Pues
porque casi ningún país europeo cultiva
granos de café.
Ahora bien, si queremos vender
ese café tostado y procesado, tendremos que
pagar un arancel especial del 7,5% ¿Por qué?
Pues porque Europa sí tiene fábricas que
procesan el café. Y no les gusta la competencia.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando! Oh, la
malvada Unión Europea, que castiga a los
países del tercer mundo ¡Esos burócratas
de Bruselas que quieren acabar con el libre
comercio! Pues… lo cierto es que prácticamente
TODOS los países del mundo hacen lo mismo.
Es más, en lo que a aranceles se refiere,
Europa es una de las regiones más abiertas
del mundo.
Por ejemplo ¿Aranceles para el café procesado?
20% ¿Aranceles para los plátanos? Entre
el 40 y el 50%. Y así, suma y sigue ¿Y qué
me decís de Estados Unidos? Pues prácticamente
igual. Casi ningún país parece dispuesto
a dejar que sus agricultores compitan en igualdad
de condiciones con los del resto del mundo.
Sin embargo… todo eso puede cambiar ¿Por
qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
MALOS TIEMPOS PARA EL PROTECCIONISMO
Todos los años, Europa se gasta más de 72.000
millones de dólares en subvencionar a sus
agricultores. Pero, como os podéis imaginar,
no todos los países miembros pagan la misma
cantidad. Fijaos en la gráfica. Aquí podéis
ver cuales son los principales contribuyentes
netos. Es decir quienes pagan más de lo que
reciben.
Y ¡Sorpresa! ¿Quien es el tercer mayor contribuyente
de la PAC? ¡Efectivamente! Reino Unido. Justo
el país que está a punto de marcharse de
la Unión. Como os podéis imaginar, esto
deja un agujero de 12.000 millones de euros.
Un agujero lo suficientemente grande como
para que muchos propongan que el resto de
los estados miembros empiecen a pagar más
para mantener el mismo gasto.
Sin embargo, casi nadie está por la labor
de pagar más. En un momento donde los partidos
políticos euroescépticos tienen más fuerza
que nunca, ningún político quiere volver
a su país diciendo “preparad la cartera,
que ahora tenemos que contribuir más por
estar en la Unión Europea”. Así que esto
es matemática pura y dura. Si no hay dinero
para pagar las ayudas, sólo queda una opción.
Básicamente, Europa ha tenido que reducir
las ayudas directas a los agricultores. Y
han decidido empezar con los más ricos, que
supuestamente son los que menos las necesitan.
Pero lo más sorprendente fue el discurso
de Macrón. Todo el mundo en Europa se esperaría
que Francia saldría a la palestra defendiendo
que la PAC siguiera como está. Sin embargo,
Macrón tiene otras prioridades. Y eso significa
luz verde para poder seguir recortando estas
ayudas en el futuro.
Y mientras tanto, cada vez va siendo más
habitual encontrarse noticias como esta.
Es decir, que muy lentamente, la Unión Europea
está reduciendo ayudas, reduciendo aranceles
y acabando con esas cuotas de producción
de las que hablábamos antes. Y os preguntaréis
¿Por qué? Pues, aparte del Brexit, los políticos
europeos se han dado cuenta de dos cosas.
Por un lado, la agricultura Europea es ya
mucho más productiva que la de, prácticamente,
cualquier país del mundo. En este otro vídeo
os hablábamos de cómo Holanda es el líder
mundial en exportación de patatas y tiene
lo que podríamos llamar el Silicon Valley
de la tecnología alimentaria ¡Pero no son
los únicos! Las exportaciones de alimentos
no dejan de crecer. Es más, estoy seguro
de que los que veáis este vídeo desde cualquier
país de Latinoamérica podréis encontrar
en cualquier supermercado vino de Ribera del
Duero o queso Camembert. Son productos Europeos
que están dando la vuelta al mundo. En otras
palabras, que Europa ya no quiere proteger
su mercado sino todo lo contrario. Quieren
hacer pactos de libre comercio con todos los
países posibles para poder seguir exportando.
Y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando ahora…
¿De verdad los agricultores Europeos se van
a poner contentos cuando dejen de recibir
tantas ayudas y tengan que competir en el
mercado internacional? Pues… probablemente
no. Pero, seamos honestos, la agricultura
ya no tiene el peso político que tenía en
los años 60. Por ejemplo, en la época de
De Gaulle, Francia tenía a millones de personas
trabajando en la agricultura. Hoy en día,
a duras penas llegan al 3% de la población.
Eso significa muchísima menos presión política…
y muchísimos menos votos. Y por si todo esto
fuera poco… ¿A quién diríais que votan
los agricultores franceses?
¡Exacto! En términos generales, los mayores
caladeros de votos de los partidos euroescépticos
están en las zonas rurales. Las zonas más
agrícolas. Así que, puestos a cortejar a
votantes, las instituciones de la Unión Europea
prefieren prestar atención a la gente que
vive en las ciudades. Gente que ni siquiera
sabe, a duras penas, lo que es la Política
Agraria Común.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿Tiene futuro
la PAC en Europa? ¿O vamos a ver pronto una
liberalización de la agricultura? ¿Hasta
qué punto Europa podría contagiar al resto
de países? ¿Veremos un día el fin de los
aranceles en el mundo de la alimentación?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!